>>> WELCOME BACK TO THE LEAD,
OUR POP CULTURE LEAD PAYING
TRIBUTE TO JERRY WEINTRAUB, HE
MAY NOT BE A HOUSEHOLD NAME TO
MANY OF YOU.
HE'S ONE OF THE CREATIVE JEAN
YOUSS BEHIND "THE KARATE KID,"
"DINER" AND "OCEAN'S 11."
HE WAS ONE OF THE FIRST MUSIC
AGENTS PROMOTING ELVIS PRESLEY
AND FRANK SINATRA.
NOW THOSE WHO KNEW HIM BEST ARE
TRYING TO SAY GOOD-BYE TO AN
ICON WHO DIED SUNDAY AT THE AGE
OF 77.
>> I'M TALKING ABOUT THIS MAN.
THE PRODUCER WHO PUT FRANK
SINATRA CERTAINER STAGE AT
MADISON SQUARE GARDEN FOR THE
MAIN EVENT.
THE CONCERT PROMOTER WHO
DISCOVERED JOHN DENVER THE
MOVIEMAKER WHO CREATED
SPOTLIGHTS FOR STARS AND MANAGED
TO OUTSHINE MOST OF THEM.
>> I MADE AN EVENT OUT OF
EVERYTHING IN MY LIFE.
>> JERRY WEINTRAUB WAS A GIANT
OF SHOW BUSINESS FOR MORE THAN
50 YEARS.
>> I'M SUPPOSED TO BE IN AN OLD
MEN'S HOME, I'M NOT GOING.
>> HE WAS KNOWN FOR HIS WELL
KNOWN ROLODEX FILLED WITH MANY
NOR SUCCESSES THAN FAILURES.
>> I WANT TO FILL YANKEE STADIUM
AND I WANTED TO DO THIS AND
THAT.
AND I KNEW I WAS GOING TO DO IT.
>> HE WORKED WITH ELVIS, NEIL
DIAMOND AND DOLLY PARTON BEFORE
BECOMING A PRODUCER OF DOZENS OF
FILMS FROM NASHVILLE.
>> FOR MOVIE LOVERS.
>> THE DARNEDEST THING YOU'VE
EVER SEEN.
>> TO THE KARATE KID.
>> EVEN HOSTING HIS FRIENDS THE
BUSH'S ON SET WHEN GEORGE
HERBERT WALKER BUSH WAS VICE
PRESIDENT.
>> IT'S IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT SHOW BUSINESS IS
A BUSINESS.
WEINTRAUB'S RENOWNED CHARM
HELPED HIM LURE BIG NAMES TO
SMALL PROJECTS AND TURN IT INTO
BLOCKBUSTERS.
>> YOU HAVE A LOT OF STORIES.
>> THE OCEAN'S 11 FRANCHISE MAY
HAVE BEEN HIS MOST FAMOUS, HIS
FILM BEFORE LIBERACE, HBO'S
BEHIND THE CANDELABRA MAY HAVE
RECEIVED THE MOST PRAISE.
I ASKED HIM ABOUT THE PROJECT IN
2013.
>> HOW DOES LIBERACE SIZE UP IN
TERMS OF ENTERTAINERS, THESE BIG
LEGENDARY ENTERTAINERS YOU'VE
WORKED WITH.
>> HE WAS A VERY FLAMBOYANT
ENTERTAINER, HE WAS MR. SHOW
BUSINESS, MR. SHOW MAN, HE WAS A
SHOW MAN.
>> AS FOR THIS SHOW MAN, THE
SPOTLIGHT STILL SHINES.
HE WAS EXECUTIVE PRODUCING HBO'S
THE BRINK AT THE TIME OF HIS
DEATH.
AND HAS A REMAKE OF TARZAN
COMING OUT THIS YEAR.
AS RICH COHEN WROTE THIS
MORNING, THE NEON LIG